-Tonight's guest is a
Golden Globe nominated actress
and Grammy-winning
country music star.
She stars in
"Big Sky: Deadly Trails,"
which premieres September 21st
on ABC.
Let's take a look.
-How's it look?
-Well, it's crooked, hon.
Pull it up on the right
just a little bit.
-That's good enough.
-Now, Buck, these people
paid good money
for a luxury back-country
experience.
The least you could do
is hang the damn sign straight.
-Well, I --
-This is a new site for us, hon.
We gotta make it shine.
-[Quietly] I'm aware of that.
-What was that?
-Uh, I love you, dear.
-Please welcome back to the
show, Reba McEntire, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Alright!
Nice.
-So happy to have you here,
Reba!
How are you doing?
-I'm doing great.
Good to be here.
-It's great to have you.
You play the questionable owner
of a glamping site
on this show, and I'm wondering
if you have done any glamping in
real life.
-Absolutely not.
-What about camping?
-No. No.
-Any camping?
Okay, why not?
Not even growing up,
you never went camping?
-No. My idea of camping is
Holiday Inn.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-How many agree with me?
[ Cheering ]
That's what I thought.
-Now, to be fair, that probably,
to some degree,
is because you did grow up
on a ranch,
and so the allure of camping
probably had...yeah.
I get it.
-No, we were up in the hills,
gathering cattle,
working cattle.
I got lost several times,
me and my little sister Susie.
Alice and Pake knew where they
were going, we never did.
It was 8,000 acres,
so we got lost.
-Right.
-So I wanted to be home.
-Yeah. So you would
accidentally go camping.
[ Both laugh ]
-Unplanned.
-Unplanned camping.
You have said, and this does
make sense to me,
growing up on a ranch helped you
both as a musician
and as an actor,
because you have to take
a lot of direction on a ranch.
What kind of direction
are you receiving?
-If, when we leave --
this is Daddy talking --
"Alright, we're gonna take these
150 head of cattle
along down there.
You sit in that gate
and make sure
nobody gets around
and gets back up in the hills."
And you heard about
a fourth of that.
So you're going,
"Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Yes, sir."
Then he'd ride off and I'd say,
"Grandpap, what did he say?"
"He said sit in the gate."
I said, "Okay."
[ Laughter ]
-There you go.
-And you better be in that gate
when Daddy gets back.
-So you could take
direction well.
We actually have a blooper reel
from your show, "Reba,"
where you are receiving
direction.
-Oh, no.
-Because it seems that
everyone involved
thinks that your pronunciation
of the word "ice"
sounds a little bit too much
like "ass."
[ Laughter ]
-Even on my phone,
when I dictate a message,
it does that.
-Really?
-Yes.
I say "iced tea,"
it goes "ass tea."
I'm like, "I did not say that."
-Don't accidentally ever order
on Amazon by voice, you know?
You never want the ass tea
to show up.
Let's take a look at
this reel real quick.
-Okay.
[Heavily accented ] Chewing ice.
Chewing ice.
-[ Laughs ]
-Ice.
[ Man shouting off seat ]
-Ice!
[ Laughter ]
-Even the judge thought
that was funny.
-Even the judge, yeah.
I have to ask about a cameo
you did
in one of my favorite films
from the last couple years,
called "Barb and Star go to
Vista Del Mar."
[ Cheering ]
-Thank you!
-And you played -- you said,
was it a water sprite?
What did they say?
-Water spirit.
-A water spirit, excuse me.
-Not a Sprite. Not like
a water Coke or a water 7-Up.
[ Laughter ]
-Excuse me, it's a water spirit.
And now, how do you...
When you get a call, how do they
explain it to you,
what you're being offered?
-Well, I was just like you.
When they said, "You're gonna be
playing a water spirit,"
and I said, "Like a mermaid?"
"No."
"Then what's a water spirit?"
"Kind of like a mer--"
"See? A mermaid."
[ Laughter ]
-I think mermaid's pretty close
to what you are.
-I do, too.
-And you just showed up
for a couple days,
jumped in the water,
and knocked it out, right?
-Yeah, yeah. It was in the bay
there in Cancun.
-Wow, so that's not a bad way
to a couple days' work.
-Heck no. Loved it.
Had a lot of fun.
-Yeah, well, they're very fun.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Annie and Kristen are pretty
fun people.
-We got to go out
and eat dinner with them.
And they had just come
from Mexico City,
where they got food poisoning.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
So they told us all that story.
They're hysterical.
-That's a fun story to hear
at dinner.
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't think about that.
-Hey, this is really cool.
I guess it's
the 45th anniversary
of the first time you played
the Grand Ole Opry.
-It is.
-What are your memories
of that night?
-Mom and Daddy
and my sister Alice
drove 650-700 miles
from Oklahoma to be with me
at my debut at
the Grand Ole Opry.
'Cause we'd been going there
forever, all my life.
Matter of fact, that's about
the only vacation we took,
was to Nashville to see
the Grand Ole Opry
at the Ryman Auditorium.
So when we pulled up to the back
entrance of Grand Ole Opry,
Daddy rolled down his window.
The gentleman stepped up
with his clipboard,
and Daddy said, "Reba McEntire,
performing on the show tonight."
And that guy went --
"Not tonight."
My heart stopped,
and Daddy said,
"Well, feller, what do you think
we ought to do?"
And he said,
"Well, I suggest you go home."
He said,
"Well, we can't do that.
We drove 700 miles to get here."
So I said, "Daddy, let's go
across the interstate
to the Get-and-Go,
and I'll call my agent."
So I did, and he said,
"You just go right back there."
We pulled up again
and the guy said,
"Right over there.
Number 28, Mr. McEntire.
So glad y'all are here."
-Wow.
-And then,
I got inside and got my
little outfit on,
and they came up to me and said,
"Reba, we're gonna have to take
one of your songs tonight."
I said, "I only get to do one?"
They said, "Yeah."
I said, "Why?"
They said, "Well, Dolly Parton
just pulled in parking lot,
and we're gonna give her
one of your songs."
I said, "Shoot, she can have
both of them."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, so the first night,
Dolly was in the building
the same night you did
your first performance
at the Grand Ole Opry.
That's really something.
-Yeah.
-How about that? And you're back
on tour this year as well.
-I am.
-Is that exciting?
-Oh, my gosh. We're so excited.
We went January-February-March
touring,
and we hadn't toured in 2 years,
and that's the first time --
I just don't know when the last
time was that I had 2 years off.
Ever. Never.
-Wow.
-And so we had it ready
to go out on tour January 2020.
COVID hit, and so we've been
sitting around
waiting for the opportunity
to go back out.
We got to do January this year
and had a blast.
And the crowds were magnificent.
-Yeah, so they're still grateful
to be out again?
-They were so ready
to hear live music,
and boy, we gave our best shows,
worked our hardest.
-Well, I would expect
nothing less.
It's always such a pleasure
to see you.
Thanks so much for
making time for us tonight.
-My pleasure.
-Reba McEntire!
"Big Sky: Deadly Trails"
premieres September 21st
on ABC.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."